was hast du dir am 10 dezember
hochgeladen königsfeier er einfach mal
kein video ist ja in ordnung sonntag mal
ein bisschen chillen was hast du danach
haben am montag hochgeladen
ja auch nicht stimmig menschen ist
ziemlich abstoßend und damit herzlich
willkommen meine erste sorry dass die
letzten beiden tage kann den peers auf
meinem kanal kamen das lag ganz einfach
daran dass ich in fauna spaß bin ich
hatte viele wichtige dinge zu tun zum
beispiel musste ich mit hunden sprechen
oder ohne fonds manager aber meine damen
und herren ich halte schon in der hand
und ihr seht auch im titel eingeblendet
man mein eigenes buch heute ab 12
dezember kommt mein buch nicht raus
sollte übermorgen am 14 dezember ein was
geht
west brom aber ich bin gerade wieder zu
hause bei meiner familie angekommen
deswegen ist die belichtung auch relativ
beschissen und nicht naturell mit
tageslicht jahre euch ja schon auf
snapshot instagram twitter die letzten
wochen und monate so ein bisschen
mitgenommen was du den arbeitsprozess
für dieses buch ja angeht dass meine
mama und ich tatsächlich eigentlich
immer nur nachts zeit gefunden haben und
da immer stundenlang telefoniert haben
und an diesem buch hier zu arbeiten aber
um diesem video hier mal ein wenig
struktur zu geben würde ich sagen teilen
wir es in drei kategorien ein und zwar
erstens um was geht's überhaupt in
diesem buch
[Musik]
zweitens wie teuer wird es sein und wo
gibt es das überhaupt zu kaufen
und drittens wann kann man mich treffen
wenn ich das buch also signieren oder
wenn
[Musik]
das buch heißt hallo mein name ist luca
heja dass mein name ich habe vor einigen
monaten ein buch gelesen von caspar das
ist ein englischsprachiger youtube und
der hatte nämlich zusammen mit seiner
mutter über ereignisreiche ereignisse
seines lebens geschrieben hat mit seiner
mutter da wirklich über ereignisse
gesprochen wie er beispielsweise in
südafrika aufgewachsen ist und hat sich
da auch so ein paar sachen und
konzentriert und da hab ich mir einfach
gedacht okay das ist eine ganz coole
form der biografie über einen menschen
also dass man das jetzt nicht allein
über sich selbst schreibt oder von dem
anlass über sich selbst schreiben lässt
sondern sich einfach die mutter oder den
vater nimmt uns zusammen überlegt okay
was waren prägende ereignisse bei mir
ist es beispielsweise so dass ich und
ich denke das ist bei den meisten von
euch auch so ich kann mich nicht daran
erinnern wie ich geboren wurde
das wäre auch komisch wenn ich das
könnte allerdings habe ich halt von
meinen eltern erfahren dass ich bei
meiner geburt wirklich fast gestorben
wäre weil dynamischen um beispielsweise
meinen kopf gewickelt war und ich
eigentlich ja einfach tot eigentlich
wäre jetzt gerade das ist zum beispiel
eine geschichte auf die wir direkt zu
beginn eingehen
aber um es auf thema zurückzukommen also
auf den inhalt des buches ist meine
mutter und ich haben uns quasi haben
zusammengesetzt die erste seite ist buch
ist es übrigens wie ich in der luft bin
und dass meine mutter und ich haben uns
zusammengesetzt und haben uns
unglaublich viele meine mutter ist
sondern unglaublicher messi die behält
alles alt also bilder von mir von vor 20
jahren und so haben wir unten immer noch
im keller wir haben uns auf jeden fall
wirklich 10 20 kisten genommen wo nur
fotos drin waren die alle perfekt
betitelt waren mit 1999 2000 2001 waren
alle möglichen quasi lebensjahre von mir
dokumentiert auf bildern und wir haben
uns diese ganzen bilder angeschaut und
jedes einzelne bild durchgegangen haben
uns gedacht okay zu welchen bildern
könnte man geschichten erzählen und wir
konnten zu jedem bild eigentlich eine
geschichte erzählen da das buch
allerdings nicht 40.000 seiten lang
werden soll sondern die das auch noch
irgendwie in eurem rucksack kriegen
sollte haben wir uns darauf geeinigt
dass wir nicht zu jedem bild beschreiben
sondern nur zu den wichtigsten sachen
also um auf den punkt zu kommen meine
mutter und ich sind quasi alle bilder
durchgegangen die wir irgendwie von mir
je gemacht haben und wenn wir gedacht
haben okay dazu fällt mir eine lustige
anekdote ein um eine mutter sieht das
aber ganz anders als ich und will dabei
das zu erzielen zb die kindergeburtstage
wo ich mir wehgetan habe und mir hier
unten was gebrochen habe da hat meine
mutter beispiel seite zugesagt nok das
ist sowieso passiert ich habe mir
allerdings gedacht ich hatte das schon
so in erinnerung und dann haben wir den
text normal beispielsweise so
dem text meiner mutter gemacht damit den
so visualisierte meine sachen dann quasi
als anmerkungen am rand das war jetzt
nicht der geburtstag das war wo ich den
fußball talk geschenkt bekommen hatte
und sogar sein wollte wie oliver kahn
aber das mit ihrem buch das in das
inhalt der inhalt des buches ist quasi
mein leben mein leben ist nicht krass
interessant aber auch nicht krass oder
interesse hey meine freunde
es macht ich hab' ich habe gerade
überlegt ob ich euch ein bisschen was
vorlesen soll das dem buch aber das ist
wirklich keine normale biografie wie ich
jetzt beispielsweise lukas rausgebracht
hat oder sowohl zusammen mit einem
reiter war ihm dabei geholfen hatte und
das ist megageil geworden von lukas
ampel des echten megatrucks buch
geworden bei uns ist es halt mehr so
dass meine mutter nicht uns
zusammengesetzt haben und meine mutter
hat immer auf schlag das bild auf
und da kommt niebels peinliches bild von
mir einen spiegel bei uns ist es halt
mehr so aufgebaut dass wir nicht normal
text haben sondern eine mutter hat
vieles geschrieben und ich habe viele
sachen wieder durchgestrichen habe
sachen umgeschrieben und deswegen
entstehen keine richtige lesefluss muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen wenn ich das
jetzt vorlesen würde beispiel hier das
geben weil meine erste große liebe und
es hat einfach alles durch gestrichen
weil meine mutter namen rein geschrieben
hat und alles und beispielsweise hier da
ist ein bisschen mehr text dafür
allerdings sind hier anmerkungen im
rahmen die geht es beispielsweise um
einen youtube start und da hat meine
mutter geschrieben als ich das erste mal
ein video von luca gesehen habe da hatte
er seinen ersten kanal mit 2000
abonnenten schon wieder gelöscht und den
aktuellen kanal konkreter gestartet dann
hab ich hier ein sternchen gemacht und
habe meine anmerkung an rand geschrieben
mama andersrum genau andersrum weil ich
hatte ja erst den anderen kanal um dann
einen neuen kanal zu machen es lief dann
kann sie so ab dass meine mutter und ich
bin wirklich mal zu sagen wie wir daran
gearbeitet haben wir haben ein mikrofon
hingestellt und meine mutter hat erzählt
januar gemacht das war hier so und so
und ich so mama zb eine ganz lustige
sache ist auch meine mutter hat immer
playboy anstatt gameboy gesagt und im
ganzen buch wenn ihr playboy seht ist
innerhalb von mir immer doller
durchgestrichen daran steht gameboy weil
die ist irgendwie nicht also ja das was
ich meine auf jeden fall sich das ganze
buch hat eigentlich normal geschrieben
aus allerdings an zwischendurch so von
mir einfach sachen komplett
durchgestrichen hier sind
da also wir haben alle haben entweder
der gesichter aus haben mich zum
beispiel zensiert weil ich dann nicht
weiß ob die leute das wollen nicht ja
auch sehr viel privates von mir drinnen
in der tat waren wir zum beispiel am
gardasee
da geht es darum dass meine mutter mal
bei mir hier tatsächlich hier
das ist tatsächlich hier wo ich gerade
bin das war mein erstes richtiges
videothek wird man nun mal der montag
mein zimmer saubergemacht und wollte
einfach nur nett sein mein zimmer sauber
machen und ich war übel sauer weil bei
dem zimmer sauber machen als die alle
reklame und das mikro umgeschmissen oder
alles von danach wochenlang nicht meine
arbeit nach wie mama auf jeden fall sind
solche ganzen sachen da drin also wir
können jetzt mal einfach auf die seite
draufgehen ich stecke meinen finger hier
ein zb hier war meine schwester und ich
halten hat in der nordsee oder wenn wir
mal auf eine andere seite gehen um
beispielsweise hier den finger
reinstecken sehen wir dass meine mutter
und ich hier da hatte ich ein neues
handy und wir haben bilder im spiegel
gemacht wir waren so guten tag alle
bilder mit blitzlicht gemacht und im
spiegel mit blitzen
der mann hat uns einfach nicht er kann
jetzt mach ich mal beispielsweise hier
finger rein was haben wir hier genau
dass ich zum ersten mal umgezogen weil
sie die bilder aus meiner ersten wohnung
wie das alles aussagen ein kühlschrank
weil er sich können jetzt alles direkt
auch erzählen was wir da geschrieben
haben aber das geht ja da noch im buch
es sind sehr viele private bilder drin
also hier beispielsweise also da sehe
ich zum beispiel richtig gut aus oder
tier paar ältere sachen oder hier da die
ich zum ersten mal das fenster raus
gekommen habe ich mit meinem werk
gefeilt hat er hier sicher hat fällt aus
ja ich war nicht immer stammt das ganze
buch hat 198 lese seiten hier ist noch
ein kleiner persönlicher text von mir
hinten drin und wie gesagt hat mir
wirklich unglaublich viele bilder zu
denen uns auch geschichten angefallen
habe ich zeige euch jetzt immer so ein
bisschen die wir aber unbedingt im buch
drin haben wollten allerdings wir sind
wer das buch damit zu krass gewesen und
das sind halt diese ganzen bilder hier
und ja genau dann ist hier noch mal so
ein bisschen das ganze wieder anregen
sucht blog dargestellt
ich stand
das ist also der inhalt von diesem buch
als wirklich auch 200 seiten meinen alle
prägenden ereignisse meines lebens zu
denen uns lustige geschichten
eingefangen sind traurige geschichten es
beispielsweise drin wie unsere kaninchen
gestorben sind jetzt eins gestorben ist
das von meiner schwester und ich mal
sind die sachen drin und meine mom und
ich uns gedacht haben okay das könnte
interessant sein für euch deswegen ja
kommen wir zu punkt nummer zwei weil ich
leider schon wieder verlangen
wir sind beste lauf amazon das buch
kommen dass übermorgen kleine rote ihr
könnt das buch eigentlich in so gut wie
jeder buchhandlung kaufen also es wird
safe in jeder mission meine ich eben wie
sonst wenn das doch nicht sein sollte
bei euch im buchhändler und die hecke zb
bei uns um die ecke haben dies einfach
schon ist es gerade der zwölfte bei
amazon ist das buch ebenfalls drin und
zwar kostet 12 euro und wer den artikel
wirklich jetzt schon unterstellen sollte
oder übermorgen oder so der kommt
erzählt noch vor weihnachten andern
sogar aber wie gesagt zu sich selbst aus
ob ihr buch kaufen möchte doch wie soll
ich kaufen möchte ich würde auf jeden
fall sehr freuen warte das war's
tatsächlich schon mit infos
wir sind gerade in der planung was
signierstunden angeht ich hatte zum
beispiel bei meinem letzten buch der
megal eine signierstunde in der
mayerschen in köln gemacht wir gucken
gerade was eventuell interessant wäre
hinsichtlich interviews euch auch
interessieren könnte dann hinsichtlich
fernsehen und solar werde ich euch
allerdings nochmal darüber informieren
in einem gesonderten video dann und
halte auf instagram folgt mir mal wir
haben jetzt 1,9 millionen follower zwei
millionen wert auch blitz also habe ich
dazu eigentlich noch keine genauen
konkreten informationen allerdings was
ich euch sagen kann das gut kommt
übermorgen raus es ist nicht limitiert
also wenn jetzt nichts machen möchte
dann könnt es euch auch noch später
irgendwann kaufen wenn jetzt vor
weihnachten oder zu weihnachten haben
möchte dann solltet ihr es halt schon
relativ zeitnah aber wie gesagt ich
möchte euch dazu nicht zwingen wir haben
wirklich einen sinn ecke menge scheiß
arbeit da reingesteckt das waren so
viele nächte die meine mutter und ich
einfach durchgearbeitet habe ich glaube
ihr habt ihr gesehen dass ich wochenlang
immer um vier uhr nachts unter anderem
arbeiten war das war uns sehr wichtig
dass das ganze von uns sehr sehr
persönlichen touch bekommt weil das ja
natürlich auch freunde von mir lesen und
ja wir wollten einfach dass es perfekt
wird deswegen auch united ich wollte das
cover übrigens so viele möglichkeiten
nicht wir haben ganz viele cover
vorschläge bekommen von schülern 70 und
flic flac die waren alle mit einem
gesicht drauf und so wie ich mir gibt
mir also die ende ich also ich finde das
so schön es war also schreibt mal in die
kommentare ob ihr das gefährt das war
die ganze zeit schon um werden video
weil deutschland und so weiter vom buch
immer schön mit doppel bleiben freunde
also kann erst mal deine fresse an luca
[Musik]